it's officially week nine of google
cloud next on air which means we're
focusing on business application
platform
i'm priyanka and welcome to this week in
cloud where we're taking a sneak peek at
this week's content
week nine is all about the business
application platform
meaning we want to help your business be
productive
so we've got a content lineup that
focuses on how to innovate with an api
first approach
as well as how employees can create apps
without coding
be sure to explore the session catalog
for interesting advice that could
simplify your own day-to-day work
our final spotlight is shining on this
authentication talk which breaks down
the many
options and considerations that your
enterprise faces
from understanding the basic differences
to identifying what factors matter most
to your company
this session is sure to answer some of
your questions
my pick of the week is unlocking the
power of your existing data
through apis because it addresses a
challenge that we all end up facing
eventually
what to do with the information that's
locked away in legacy systems
or on paper it's really interesting
to see all of the solutions that are
available and how different products
approach the same problem with a unique
perspective
if you're like me then be sure to add
this one to your playlist
finally be sure to check out this video
demo of
app sheets a tool that enables employees
to create their own
applications without needing to write
any code
even pro engineers like tools that are
easy to use and app sheet packs a lot of
the features
into a deceptively simple package to add
these sessions to your digital playlist
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us using the
hashtag
google cloud next we'll see you in the
cloud